but for the women after we had our
wonderful presentation from alex
do you think women
have a sort of lineup like that to get
what they essentially want from men and
that's
either money
time or whatever they value in a man
i think women will always know what
they're doing like i said earlier people
might bat like they're vulnerable but
people are not dumb and if you're a
woman who's realistic with yourself
and you're playing a game you want to
talk about hoes and strippers and girls
in the streets
there's girls out there that know how to
play men but also the men know what
they're doing they they actually enjoy
it so it's a mutual risk like
like everyone's get what they want
during the day but i think women do know
how to play the game
but i think there's women personally in
my circle that don't play the game
but there's women that can play the same
exact game
simple as
obviously it's a bit different for a man
women will use sex to get what they want
from a man
i think women develop much more
sophisticated games very early on quite
naturally so i was a massive physics
teacher for a while and i noticed that
pretty much 15 14 starts as long as even
12 like you know year 7.
these girls are already lying they're
already practicing like triangular
relationships like love triangles
because all girls watch is romance right
the the eternals you know
they idolize that stuff they practice
for these complex situations and in fact
some and oftentimes they actually want
these situations to happen because they
enjoy these scenarios kind of like every
man wants to be the man every girl wants
to be the guy that you know the girl
that guys fight over inherently and so
women naturally develop much more
sophisticated ways of playing the game
also they have something you want right
sex so
naturally they start learning how to
filter and how to play the game but
because of social media it tinged the
game too much in favor of attention
before i think i think there was other
things in the courting process right she
would she would kind of think more about
like his ability to take care of her xyz
but now because of social media and the
dopamine you get from like having people
look at you and like your stuff and
people think you're great and having
that clout young girls are got kind of
seduced into this like i want to play
this game
women are constantly getting my
attention and validation that they want
look at it
there's no need there's no need past
that point to give anything up they're
getting the intention and validation
that men usually
don't just give out for free i want to
hear your two's uh
answers to my question
i'm just interested
yeah i feel like i've been talking a lot
so i'm just you know i'm just taking
everything in but i i i agree i think i
think women know how to play the game i
think we know what we want to do
but i think that's a general thing not
every woman knows exactly
what
a game is or what they maybe even want
i just no don't worry i just feel like
i know we're not talking completely
generally but i feel like
opinions here are very much like black
and white i think that's why i've kind
of just been
very in the you know fly on the wall
type thing
um and i also don't like to interrupt
that's kind of why i've just been
sitting here but i think at the end of
the day we all men and women we all know
what we want
at the end of the day so
i think modern women don't know what
they want
i
in regards to like
women naturally learning that it
actually a lot of it starts at home
and it's very very common you see this
in studies where the daughters will and
the daughter and the mother start
competing for the father's attention
and it's very common because it's his
little girl that she almost takes
priority because how many times do we
see
like a daughter who has that her father
wrapped around her finger right
especially if he's like very wealthy or
whatever and all this so it actually
starts a lot of it can start very very
young and it's really common that it
starts young especially when you've got
the father in the home and that's almost
how she learns how to get the male
attention she doesn't you don't even
realize that it's from the parents but
it is
so just to play
what about the other ones that didn't
have a dad or vice versa because
sometimes it doesn't always just play on
social media yeah of course i mean but i
mean it starts it can happen at school
as well likes to start at school
women know which women get the attention
the girls go on their instagram and they
see that the girls the women who have
the attention who are being shared
that's modern day yeah yeah
that's that's that's modern day in terms
of online
but i'm talking like let's say just
classic in the playground or something
like or you're just like at school i i
agree with you because like i would say
um my family has a lot of like high
achievers and because that's kind of how
we would compete for our parents
attention was like doing good at sports
or doing good at like whatever yeah so
you get validation yeah yeah yeah yeah
so is this one can you hear me um yes
sir yeah it should be on
yeah i was on yeah yeah so young boys
typically they try to gain
their parents approval through
achievements and accolades yes whereas
girls typically use
the
the manipulation tactic of
i'm basically upset or i'm hurt which
which makes it brings out the nurturing
uh so it brings it brings out that side
of men that's protective and makes men
want to protect the daughters which
gives them the attention it was a
manipulation tactic
but then with nowadays if we look at
society how many men are in
their children life like in their
daughter's life how many women are in
their son's life like if we look at both
there's
a lot of men that are not there women
that are not there for the kids vice
versa they're growing up without a full
family loving them and understanding
what to look for in a man manner in a
woman yeah we try which which i agree is
wrong however so how do we look for it
now that's what i'm saying like
movies instagram social media which i
believe an episode needs to be done on
by the way yeah i truly believe social
media instagram uh erotic novels
everything else oh on that point as well
for anyone who's not seen it
sex life a documentary on netflix
if you haven't watched it you [ __ ]
need to it's only 10 episodes but that
series
projects everything we've gone through
today it's an i think a good an episode
on that would be [ __ ] amazing give
that give that series a go because yeah
men you're going to be pissed
so i have i have a question for the men
what can a modern woman do for a man to
outperform what traditional women have
offered in the past
[Music]
what can a modern woman so
what can a modern woman do for a man to
outperform the traditional women
that what traditional women have offered
in the past i would say i'll say help
with this career because back back in
the day tradition like the women didn't
have the opportunities in the career
space to open doors or to provide like
even even simple things it's just like
i remember i was dating a girl once we
went and trained to the gym together and
the guy she was like attractive a guy
gave her like like a free foam thing for
training and she just gave it to me and
i was just like she used her perks
to serve my life in some way so i'll
probably say the difference is i forgot
if a woman can help a man in his career
in some way that's something that
traditional women traditionally couldn't
have done because they didn't have
access to that but i would also i would
also say instead of instead of trying to
outdo the traditional women i would say
bring back what traditional women have
their values right so be beautiful be
youthful be pure don't just be sleeping
around with everybody be feminine be
submissive and support your mind but i
think the question is as many of you
know i was just banned on tic tac and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible